parking lot of suburban laundromat a
young boy scurries past as wash and
learn text is overlaid interior
laundromat text st paul minnesota a
woman holds a children's book and speaks
to young children seated on the floor
jeff gardner chairman laundry cares
foundation wash and learn is a
combination of libraries and laundromats
coming together with communities
to promote literacy
and help early childhood learning
in spaces that might not normally be
traditionally thought of as libraries a
nicely groomed man wearing a dark gray
suit and white shirt melvin carter iii
mayor of st paul i'm really excited to
be here today this morning on a saturday
morning in a saint paul public library
we're partnering with libraries without
borders to ensure that all of our
children and families in our community
have access to books and literacy seated
on the floor melvin carter holds a book
while interacting with children a young
boy turns pages of a children's book as
other kids look on and you know two
hours spent on a saturday morning
washing are also two hours spent on a
saturday morning learning
nnlm
works with us libraries.porters adam
eckelman director of programs libraries
without borders
to pilot our first ever laundromat event
in minnesota and with some of the
learnings from that program we said why
can't we do this across the state and
now we're working in five different
counties
seven different laundromats exterior of
the laundry map shows a job fair with
people milling about
um to
really think about how do we get
information to people where they are how
do we ensure that nlm resources reach
the families that they're intended to
serve pangyang community service
coordinator rondo community library this
is a very natural space for families to
already be and to go to weekly and so we
figured
let's destroy
the transportation barrier or the time
barrier or whatever the obstacle is and
then come to where they are so that we
can provide them the resources that we
have
adam and others standing in front of a
washing machine a woman walks by with a
filled laundry basket when people come
into the laundromat
they're not thinking about learning
they're not thinking about addressing
their concerns about diabetes or
hypertension
or
cancer
they're washing their clothes and so
what we're trying to do
is to transform the 90 minutes the wash
and dry cycle that you're doing every
week
into
to a different kind of experience into
one that's actually enriching a group of
young children seated on the floor is
reflected in the window of a front
loading clothes dryer jennifer nelson
state librarian of minnesota
digital literacy is fundamental to being
successful in the world today and i
think many of us take for granted the
fact that we have computers at home that
we have access to wi-fi a group of young
boys are seated around a table with
laptop computers adam and a child look
at a screen showing the medlineplus
website the national library of medicine
a lot of people aren't aware of the
degree in nature of the resources that
they put out to make learning about
topics related to medicine really
accessible to people so we've got some
websites that are set up to the nlm site
i should say
where people can look for information
about nutrition some of the resources
are directed toward kids so they're
really friendly more of a game like
environment a young boy with short dark
hair jose gonzalez it was really fun
because i got to play on the computer it
was nice of them for putting all this
stuff up
middle-aged man wearing laundry care's
foundation t-shirt daryl johnson owner
giant wash coin laundry it's a way to
give back simply put if i can serve my
community
in the end it's going to be good for me
but the reality of it is it's just good
for the community montage of laundromat
patrons watch and learn organizers and
children playing